bileşik adlandırma kısmına geldik bugün
iyonik bileşiklerin adlandırması
bahsedeceğim burada bilmen gereken bir
şey var sana tablo vereceğim Bak baştan
söylüyorum bunu bu tabloyu kes bu şeyi
indir pdf'i indirdikten sonra tabloyu
kes karşına As PDF diyelim geç geldi Sen
kendin yaz bunu karşına As baka baka
yapmak zorundasın ilk başta baka baka
yaparak birazcık alıştıracak kendini
Ondan sonra örnekler daha kolay gelmeye
başlayacak ne yazık ki burası biraz
ezber kısmı Ben elimden geldiğince
mantığını an Anlatmaya çalışacağım ama
bu adlandırmada bir tablo var ki bu
tablonun karşında olması sana çok fayda
sağlayacak dostum bir de geçenlerde
eşimle konuşuyordum dedi ki ya o kadar
bak içerik çekiyorsun şöyle bir
gösterdim işte abone olmadan
izleyenlerin sayısı fazla Sanki boşuna
mı uğraşıyorsun gibi bir şey söyledi
dedim Yok öğrencilerim beni üzmez boşuna
uğraşmıyorum Ben onlar için içerik
çekmeye devam edeceğim onlar da abone
olacaktır gelin şu benim hanımı bir
utandır alım şu abone olursanız çok
mutlu olurum ben de artistlik yapacağım
ona Hadi O Zaman Derse başlayalım şimdi
iyonik bileşiklerin adlandırılmasında
sana şimdi Dedim ya birazdan tablo
vereceğim o tablo üzerinden rahat rahat
örneklerimiz yapacağız kurallarımız var
Birazdan bahsedeceğim Ama şöyle bir şey
var mesela bazı örnekler var nac
diyorduk bu sofra tuzu ya da Yemek tuzu
diyorduk Ama bunun bilimsel bir ismi var
mesela sodyum klorür Bu nasıl söyleniyor
birazdan açıklayacağım Nah C şey pardon
E bu neymiş sodyum bikarbonat bileşiği
yaygın adı mesela yemek sodası ama
normalde buna işte sodyum bikarbonat
böyle bir şey var işte bu h co3
bikarbonat kökü veya işte şuna kireç
taşı diyorduk C C3 bu aslında Kalsiyum
karbonat bunların işte açıklamasını
yapacağım birazdan ve iyonik bileşikler
adlandırılırken işte Öncelikle işte
katyon adı sonra anyon adı o şekilde
sırayla söylenmekte Burada da onu
söylüyor adlandırmada kullanılacak katon
Van anyonlar aşağıda belirtilmiştir
diyor değişken değerlik alanlar var yani
bazı elementler var ki birden fazla
değerlik alabiliyor şöyle örnek vereyim
sana mesela mesela bunu neye benzettiğim
söyleyeceğim mesela mesela Hatta pb
demeyeyim ya fcl 3 var ve fcl L2 var
mesela a hocam demir var Klor var Demir
klorür ikisi de mi Demir klorür farklı
değil mi bileşikler sonuçta biri fcl 3
diğeri fc2 işte burada üstteki Demir + 3
almakta alttaki Demir de + 2 almakta
Bundan dolayı da üsttekine Demir 3
klorür alttakine Demir 2 klorür ismi
verilmektedir niye bunu veriyor Bak ne
dedi Demir 3 klorür burada 3 tane klor
olduğu için mi söylüyor Hayır Demir 3
demirin + 3 olduğunu ifade ediyor veya
işte Demir 2 demirin + 2 olduğunu ifade
ediyor başka bir örnek vereyim Mesela bu
dediğinin hani sadece Klor sayısına göre
olmadığını göstermek için pbo var mesela
pbo2 var oksijen -2 yüklü olduğu için
buradaki Kurşun + 2 yüklüdür şimdi
oksijen -2 yüklü 2 tane oksijen -4
olduğu için buradaki kurşuna + 4 Bak
burada şunu demiyorsun Kurşun 1 oksit
Kurşun 2 oksit demiyorsun hangi yükü
aldığın söylüyoruz Bak bunun ismi mesela
Kurşun 2 oksit Neden Çünkü Kurşun Burada
+ 2 alıyor o zaman bunun ismi ne olur
Kurşun 4 oksit olur mesela hangi yükü
aldığını değişken değerlikler de Ne
yapıyoruz belirtiyoruz şimdi gel
bazılarını bilmemiz gerekenleri işte
karşımızda böyle asılı durması
gerekenleri gösteriyorum hidrojen + 1
aldığı için ismi hidrojen artı yüklerde
isim doğrudan veriliyor Mesela işte H +
hidrojen lityum + 1 lityum Bu ne mesela
işte na + bir sodyum K + 1 potasyum k
ile şey mesela çok karıştırılır k'ye
kalsiyum diyenler çıkıyor Hayır K
potasyumdan oluyor Hayır bu
fosfordan bahsedeceğim gümüşün yani
ag'nin evet genel olarak biz + 1 olarak
görüyoruz çok güzel ama çok nadir de
olsa gümüşün + 2 olduğu durumlar varmış
Bunu da ben mesela geçen bir araştırma
sonucunda fark ettim gümüşün Nadir e
Halit bileşikleri miydi Öyle hadit mi
Halit mi öyle bileşikleri var Gümüş
halitler Orada mesela + 2 aldığı
durumlar da söz konusuydu bugüne kadar
mesela hep şöyle öğretiliyordu Gümüş
sadece + 1 alır diye söyleniyordu Hayır
gümüşün + 2 olduğu durumlar da söz
konusuydu bunu da ekstradan bildirmiş
olayım işte Gümüş Tamam ev1 Gümüş burada
Mesela civa bak civa + 1 de alıyor + 2
de alıyor O yüzden Bak buna civa 1
diyorsun + 1 aldığı için buna civa 2
diyorsun + 2 aldığı için bakır mesela +
1 de alabiliyor + 2 de alabiliyor O
yüzden + 1 alana bakır 1 + 2 alana bakır
2 ismi veriliyor amonyum dediğimiz bir
kök vardır nh4 çok önemlidir Bunu da
bilmende fayda var nh4 + iyonu neymiş
amonyum muu buraya bakalım Kurşun mesela
+ 2 de alabiliyor + 4 de alabiliyor O
yüzden buna Kurşun 2 buna Kurşun 4
ismini veriyoruz mesela magnezyum sadece
+ 2 alır önemlidir bilmen gerekenler
bunlar Bak bu tablodakiler çok önemlidir
kalsiyum Baryum Bunlar mesela sadece + 2
alanlar çinko sadece + 2 alıyor işte
öyle söylüyoruz burada demir var mesela
Demir + 2 de alabiliyor şurada Demir + 3
de alabiliyor O yüzden buna Demir 3
diyoruz buna ne diyoruz Demir 2 diyoruz
dostum Başka ne vardı nikel mesela nikel
Burada + 2 olarak gösterilmiş başka ne
var alüminyum var sadece + 3 almakta
alüminyum yazdık geçtik ama krom + 3 de
alabiliyor + 6 da alabiliyor O yüzden
krom 3 krom 6 şeklinde ekstra
belirtiyoruz burada Kobalt Mesela ne
yapmış + 3 aldığı duruma Kobalt 3 demiş
mangan mesela + 4 de alabiliyor + 6 da
alabiliyor böyle değişken değerlikli + 4
aldığında mangan 4 + 6 aldığında işte Ne
diyoruz işte mangan 6 diyoruz Kalay var
Mesela işte Art 4 olanı Kalay 4 mesela
şuraya ekstradan yazabilirim Kalay 2
olan durumu da vardır Kalay 2 diye şöyle
belirtelim Dostum bunlar artı yüklüler
bir de eksi yüklüler var mesela hidrojen
+ 1 olduğunda ismi hidrojen ama -1
olduğunda hidrür ismini almakta Bun
Bununla ilgili örnekler vereceğim
birazdan flor Mesela ne oluyor florür
oluyor -1 hali klorür oluyor hep ür eki
gibi geliyor genel olarak bromür iyodür
-1 L mesela burada örnekler vermiş kök
olan yani Birden fazla atomdan oluşan -1
yüklüler var Kim onlar Oh -1 hidroksit
Siyanür var CN -1 Siyanür işte burada ne
var no3 -1 nitrat ch3coo ek var asetat
hco3 ek var Bu da bikarbonat mesela
burada co3 -2 karbonat co4 - 2 sülfat
po4 -3 ise mesela fosfat olarak
gösteriliyor burada Mesela oksijen -2
oksit bak oksijen değil oksit s -2
Sülfür burada ne var mesela n azotu ama
işte şey olduğunda bileşiğin içerisine
girdiğinde nitrür ismini aldı burada
p'ye baktığımızda P ne olacak işte -3
fosfür C -4 var Mesela bu da Karbür
olarak ifade ediliyor şöyle bir şey
yapacağım bak eğer hidrojen bileşiğin
başındaysa ismi hidrojen genel olarak
böyledir genel olarak ama hidrojen
bileşiğin sonunda olursa hidrür ismini
almakta başka Mesela şöyle söyleyeyim s
bileşiğin başında olursa kükürt şeklinde
söyleniyor ama bileşiğin sonunda olursa
Sülfür ismini alıyor genel olarak azot
başta olursa azot eyvallah Ama bileşiğin
sonunda olursa yani eksi yüklü olursa
nitrür ismini almakta Bunlar Bazı özel
örnekler karbon mesela bileşiğin başında
olursa karbon sonunda olursa Karbür
şeklinde söylenebilir şimdi ad
kandırmaya geldik ne dedik önce katyonun
adı sonra anyonun adı bak neyden
oluşuyor na ve CL na neydi sodyum CL
neydi klorür sodyum klorür bak Al s var
Alüminyum Sülfür ilki alüminyum ikincisi
s olduğu için Sülfür sonda olduğu için
diyebilirsin hocam iki tane alüminyum
var 3 tane de s var Onları niye
söylemedik söylemiyoruz dostum sadece
iyonik bağlı bileşiklerde farklı yük
alanlarda yani değişken değerlik
alanlarda
belirtiyorsunuz Bu ne mesela Baryum şu
ne oksijen Baryum oksijen demiyorsun bak
Baryum oksit ismini veriyorsun bu
kalsiyumdan nitrür potasyum fosfür
şeklinde söylüyoruz şuna baktığımızda bu
ne
potasyumdan aksit mi diyeceksin Hayır
co3 neydi karbonat köküyüm karbonat
Gördüğün gibi na sodyum po4 neydi Hemen
bakalım po4 fosfatı Gördüğün gibi neymiş
sodyum fosfat bu ne nh 4 nh 4'e
geliyorum nerede nerede Hemen yukarıda
nh4 amonyum duu amonyum yanındaki ne BR
amonyum bromür şeklinde söyledik mesela
Şuna bak Baryum Oh neydi hidroksit
Baryum hidroksit dedik ZN Çin koydu bu
CN yapısı neydi siyanürü çinko Siyanür e
amonyum so4 neydi Bak so4 burada sülfat
önemli bir köktür Ne oldu o zaman
amonyum sülfat ismini verdik Burada
mesela çok karıştırılanlar kısmına bir
tane daha şey yapmak istiyorum Eğer P
ile ile bitiyorsa fosfür po4 ile
bitiyorsa fosfat Bunlar karıştırılır s
ile bitiyorsa Sülfür co4 ile bitiyorsa
sülfat dikkat et buna başka n ile
bitiyorsa nitrür no3 ile bitiyorsa
nitrat tamam mı Bunları karıştırma
dikkat et bir de değişken
değerliklidir de toplam yük 0 olması
gerekiyor o zaman F nedir Burada + 2 ama
fninternbasvuru
Çünkü zaten alüminyumun + 3'ten başka
yükü yok Niye belirteyim bir daha ama
demirin var demirin + 2'si de var + 3'ü
de var Hangisini aldığını belirtmek
zorundayım değişken değerliler de o
yüzden yükü belirtiyorsunuz Bunun ismi
bak Demir + 2 olduğu için Demir 2 +
2'den dolayı Sülfür zaten s sonda
olduğunda Sülfür Şuraya bak şimdi s -2
de 3 tane olunca ne olacak burası -6 e
bileşiğin 0 olması için buranın + 6
olması gerekiyor 2 tanesi + 6 İsa F
burada neymiş + 3 3 müş Hım bak Demir +
3 aldı O zaman ne diyorsun buna Demir 3
Sülfür ismini veriyorsun Demir Çünkü + 3
aldı veya bak pb co3 bak co3 nerede co3
burada ne alıyormuş -2 geldim buraya co3
-2 alıyorsa o zaman pb de + 2 alıyordur
ama pbn yukarıdaki durumuna bak + 4
alanı da var + 2 alanı da var Hangisini
aldığını belirtmek zorundayım Yani bunun
ismi + 2 olduğu için kurşun 2 karbonat
olacak Hemen
alttakinden de vermiş sağ olsun co3
dediğimiz Yapı -2 di 2 tane olduğu için
demek ki burası -4 e bileşiğin toplam
yükünün 0 olması için pbn de + 4 olması
lazım Aha Kurşun + 4 aldı o zaman
belirtmek zorundayım Kurşun 4 karbonat
şeklinde belirtiyorum başka bir örnek
yazmak istiyorum Şurada çok önemli iki
örnek cuo ve cu2o çok karıştırılan iki
örnektir Bunlar bak oksijenin yüküne
bakalım nerede -2 yaz buraya gel rengi
değiştirerek göstereceğim oksijen -2 ise
Kurşun bu ne Kurşun bak bakır da + 2
olacaktır değil mi şuraya geldim oksijen
-2 ise o zaman şu 2 tane bakır + 2
olacaktır Yani bir tane bakır ne
olacaktır burada + 1 o zaman bak üsttek
de bakır + 2 olduğu için bunun ismi
bakır 2 oksit alttakinin ismi ise bakır
bir oksit olacaktır bak yükünü
söylüyorsun Sakın ha şu yanılgıya düşme
a hocam burada bakırdan iki tane var
Bunun ismi bakır 2 oksit olması
gerekmiyor mu Ben Bakırın sayısı ile
ilgilenmiyor arkadaşım neyle
ilgileniyorum Ben Bakırın yüküyle
ilgileniyorum üstteki bakır + 2 olduğu
için ne oldu bakır 2 oksit oldu
alttakinden bakır + 1 olduğu için bakır
1 oksit oldu tamam mı dostum peki peki
peki peki hemen sana soruyorum
al2 o3 şunun ismi nedir diye sorsam
hemen aynı mantıkla gideceksin değil mi
Bak oksijen -2 di 3 tane olduğu için
Burası -6 0 olması için Buranın da + 6
olması lazım 2 tanesi + 6 olduğuna göre
göre alüminyum burada neymiş + 3' müş
buna gidip de alüminyum nasıl yazdım la
Heh alüminyum 3 oksit dersen patates
olursun ama hocam yukarıda anlattın
Senin de Bir söylediğin bir söylediğini
tutmuyor gibi düşünebilirsin ama bak
Üzerine bastıra bastıra Az önce söyledim
değişken değerlik de belirtiyorsunuz +
3'ten başka yükü yok ki niye belirteyim
O yüzden Bunun ismi doğrudan alüminyum
oksit tamam mı değişken değerlikler de
belirtirsin tekrar hatırlatıyorum
değişken olmayanlarda söylemiyorsun
Hocam ben bunları nasıl yapacağım işte o
yüzden diyorum bu tabloyu karşına As
diye karşında Dursun ki daha rahat
anlayabilirim tamam mı dostum baka baka
yapacaksın ilk başta baka baka oradan
Seç oradan seç ismini yaz bunu seç bunu
seç yaz ismini bu şekilde gideceksin Gel
bakalım örnekler var burada Aha burada K
neydi
potasyumdan potasyum bromür yazalım
potasyum bromür Peki dur la size bir
kıyak yapacağım Dur dur Aha da kıyak
tabloyu buraya getirdim bak Aha burada
yüklerim ne diyor na ve s var na neydi
sodyumda Aha burada S neydi s burada Aha
bu da sülfürü o zaman bunun ismi ne
olacaktır sodyum Sülfür olacaktır Sülfür
bu ne Ba Baryum Oh neydi Aha hemen
Bakalım burada Oh neymiş hidroksit demiş
Demek ki bunun ismi Baryum hidroksit
olacak hidroksit peki Aha CR bak C'yi
görüyor musun + 3'ü de var + 6'sı da var
değişken değerlikli o zaman demek ki
bulmam lazım Hangi yükü aldığını bulmam
lazım şimdi s neydi hemen bakıyorum s -
2'ydi yazalım yerine s -2 ise 3 tanesi
-6 iyonik bileşiklerin toplam yükü 0
olmalı Demek ki buradaki 2C + 6 olacak E
demek ki bir tane crn yükü neymiş + 3'
müş He o zaman burada krom 3 var benim
elimde Bak krom 3 Çünkü + 3 e s ile
bittiğine göre Ne diyorduk buna Sülfür
diyorduk değil mi dostum he magnezyum
sadece + 2 alır çok güzel ilkini yaz dur
RK değiştireceğim lan H magnezyum co4
var bak co4 Neydi co4 Aha burada sülfat
mış O zaman bu magnezyum sülfat şeklinde
yazılacak e Şuna bak kalsiyum var değil
mi C
kalsiyumdan la bu Heh po4 fosfat mış o
zaman kalsiyum fosfat şeklinde ne yaptık
adlandırdıkları
oldu yazalım şuraya burada He -2 3
tanesi -6 Demek ki buranın + 6 olması
lazım 0'a eşitlemek için 2 tane F var +
6 Demek ki bir tanesi neymiş + 3' müş
Demek ki burada Demir 3 kullanmışım Ben
Demir + 3'ünü kullandığım için e co3
neydi karbonat Demir 3 karbo Onat
şeklinde adlandırıyor kalsiyum sadece +
2 alıyor O yüzden belirtmeme gerek yok
kalsiyum şeklinde söyledim bu ne n n
olduğunda Ne diyorduk sonda olduğunda
nitrür ismini veriyorduk değil mi Heh HG
değişken değerlikli şimdi şuraya bak s
-2 bir dakika bunun -2 olduğuna göre
bileşiğin toplam yükünün 0 olması için
buranın da + 2 olması lazım 2 tane HG +
2 ise demek ki bir tane HG + 1 bak civa
+ 1 de alabiliyordu nerede göstereyim
sana civa + 1 de alabiliyordu 2 de
alabiliyordu o yüzden belirtmem
gerekiyor ne diyorum buna civa 1 Çünkü +
1 olanı kullandık s ile bittiği için
Sülfür ismini verdim co3 karbonatı bak
krom neydi değişken değerlikli ydi
Burada çaprazlayarak da gösterebilirim
İstersen başka aynı örneği çözdüm gibi
gelmişti bana dur bakayım Yok çözmem şim
Tamam şimdi burada çaprazlamaya da
yapılır Ama bu da daha kolay co3 -2 di 3
tanesi -6 Demek ki 0 olması için Buranın
da + 6 olması lazım 2 tane CR + 6 olduğu
için bir tane CR + 3 Demek ki krom 3
Çünkü + 3 olanı kullandım co3 dediği
için karbonat olacaktır co3 karbonat Bak
mn bu da değişken değerlik oksijenin
yükü neydi bakalım oksijen oksit
şeklinde söylüyorduk -2 di -2 yazalım e
3 tane olunca ne oluyor -6 e bileşik
iyonik bağlı bileşikler ne oluyordu
toplam yük 0 olması lazım Burası da + 6
Aha mangan Yani mn şöyle yazalım mangan
kaç almış + 6 aldığı için belirtmem
gerekiyor 6 şöyle mangan 6 oksijen
olduğu için sonu oksit şeklinde
söylüyoruz po4 şimdi p değişken
değerlikli bulmam lazım pardon po4
demişim so4 var sonda co4 sülfat -2 ymiş
yazalım co4 -2 2 tane olunca -4 o zaman
pb burada + 4 oldu he Bunun ismi o zaman
Kurşun 4'ü kullandığım için şöyle Kurşun
4'ü kullandım Kurşun 4 sondaya sülfat
var bu şekilde belirtiyorum dostum ha bu
sefer de İsmini vermiş formülü istiyor
bak magnezyum var magnezyum + 2'ydi
klorür diyor klorür de -1 di E ne
oluyordu çaprazlayarak yapabiliyordu
değil mi bu 2'yi şunun altına bu 1'i
bunun altına
yazabiliyorsun K + 1 nitrat dediğimiz
no3 -1 e 1 + 1 1 -1 doğrudan yaz gitsin
kn3 oldu Kalsiyum karbonat kalsiyum +
2'ydi hemen gösteriyorum bak neredeydi
neredeydi Aha burada kalsiyum + 2 E
karbonat Neydi o da -2 di yazalım hemen
şöyle co3 üzeri -2 E bu aynı sayı değil
mi Bak 1 + 2 1 -2 toplam yük 0 Demek ki
ikisinden de birer tane yazsak
yetiyormuş ca co3 Heh bakır 2 nitrat Aha
bak Bakırın + 2 olduğunu anladım orada
nitrat neydi nitrat -1 di bak eşitlemek
için bir taraf + 2 bir taraf -1 -2 yee
çevirmem lazım yani şundan iki tane
almam gerekiyor He o zaman bakır
nitrattan iki tane aldığım için kökün
altına 1den büyük bir sayı gelince
paranteze alıyorduk no3 2 yazdık Heh bak
Kalay 4 oksit Kalay dediği Sayın Kalay
Sn 4 dediği için Kalay + 4 aldı e
oksitte o neydi bakıyorum tekrar hemen
burada gösterelim Aha burada Bak görüyor
musun oksitte k o -2 di yerine geldik
hemen Bu da -2 şimdi dikkat et bir taraf
+ 4 bir taraf -2 ne yapacağız şundan 2
tane alırsam + 4 -4 olur yani s n'den
bir tane oksijenden 2 tane sno2 olacak
alüminyum sülfat bak alüminyum sadece +
3 alıyor sülfat dediğimiz co4 ise -2
alıyor bunları kaçta eşitli olduk Çok
değerli dostum hemen bakalım ben şundan
2 tane alsam Şundan da 3 tane alsam bir
taraf + 6 bir taraf -6 sıfırlamış oldum
E o zaman alüminyumdan iki tane
sülfattan da 3 tane olduğu için
paranteze aldım dışına 3 yazdım dostum
Başka mangan ne bu ve 7 oksit diyor
Maşallah mangan + 7 almış Görüyor musun
E oksit diyor oksijen de -2 e Bunlar
neydi 14'te eşitlenir yani bundan 2 tane
bundan 7 tane alırsan + 144 -14 ne
olacaktır mn2 o7 bileşiği oluşacaktır
buraya bakalım Baryum fosfat Baryum
neydi renk değiştireceğim bir dakika
karışacak Çünkü Baryum Baryum dediğimiz
Art 2'ydi e fosfat dediğimiz po4 tü po4
yükü neydi Hemen küçülte bakayım
Neredesin lan aha burada fosfat
-3'ten bunu güzel insan şöyle yaparım
şundan 3 tane alırım şundan 2 tane
alırım + 6 -6 eşitlenmiş oldu Ne olacak
o zaman Baryum danan 3 ba3 po4 2 tane
po4 parantez 2 olacak bir sonraki neymiş
sodyum asetat Bak şimdi sodyum + 1
asetat dediğimiz Ch3 coo - dediğimiz bir
yapıdır var mıydı o bakıyoruz -1 lde -1
lde Evet var Bak görüyor musun asetat
dediğimiz Yapı burada He o zaman bir
taraf + 1 bir taraf -1 şöyle gösterirsek
dikkat etmen gereken bir şey var bunu
Normalde na
ch3coo şeklinde yazarsak da doğrudur ama
Bunu genel olarak şöyle göreceksin Ch3
coo olanlarda onu başa yazıyorsun
Genellikle hep artı yüklü başa yazılır
bir tek bunda böyle bir istisnai durum
var Ch3 co O O na şeklinde gösterilmekte
Aklında bulunsun dostum Hadi kaldı 3
tane burada dur lan hadi yapalım Şunları
da Bak ne diyor civa 2 diyor HG + 2 ymiş
Siyanür neydi Siyanür -1 di onu da hemen
göstereyim sana bak nerede nerede nerede
nerede Aha bak Burada nerede he
siyanürde -1 de civa 2 dediği için Öbürü
de Art 2 dediği için Aha burada Şimdi
bundan bir tane alsam şundan ik tane
alsam ne olur eşitlenmiş olur + 2 -2
yani Ne oldu HG den bir tane C n'den ik
tane olduğu için paranteze alıp böyle
yazıyorsun Sakın Ha şöyle yazma HG cn2
Böyle yazarsan sanki karbondan bir tane
azottan iki tane varmış gibi anlaşılıyor
Hayır CNN altına iki tane yazman lazım
ki içeriye dağıtasım İki karbon 2 azot
olması gerekiyor burada nikel hidroksit
diyor bak nikel sadece + 2 alan bir
yapıdır hidroksit dediğimiz is Oha
Pardon Oh -1 E şimdi alınan verileni
eşitlemek için şundan iki tane almam
lazım bundan bir tane var yani nikel oh2
yani ni2 oh2 şeklinde yazılıyor amonyum
fosfat amonyum dediğimiz nh4 artıdır po4
fosfat po4 -3 dikkat Bak şimdi ne oluyor
Burası -3 burası + 1 ne yapmam lazım
şundan 3 tane Şundan bir tane almam
lazım ki artı ve eksi sayıları
eşitlensin nh 4'ten 3 tane aldım O
yüzden nh4 3 po4 şeklinde yazılacaktır
bu bileşik şimdi bu sorulara bakalım
Diyor ki iyonik bileşiklerin
adlandırılması il ilgili bileşiği
oluşturan anyon ve katyonların sayısı
belirtilir Hayır canım Mesela örnek
vereyim al2 o3 2 Aliminyum 3 oksijen
diye belirtiyor muyum belirtmiyor gitti
bileşiği oluşturan anyon ve katyonların
isimleri söylenir Evet alüminyum oksit
bak anyonu ve katyonu söylüyorsun Doğru
önce katyon sonra anyon ifade edilir
genel olarak Doğrudur bak alüminyum
oksit önce katyon sonra anyon Doğrudur
cevap 2 3 D seçeneği olacaktır burada
diyor ki ha bileşiklerin suda
çözündüğünde oluşturduğu iyonlar h
hangisinde ne yanlış verilmiştir lityum
florür lityum + 1'di flor -1 de o yüzden
Doğrudur bu Aynen böyledir gümüş nitrat
dediğinde Gümüş + 1 alıyor genel olarak
nitrat -1 alıyor O yüzden bu da doğrudur
sodyum + 1 asetat -1 dirir sodyum asetat
verir doğru bak Baryum Siyanür diyor
Baryum + 2'ydi Siyanür -1 de evet doğru
çinko sülfat diyor bak çinko + 2'dir
sülfat dediği co4 - 2'dir burada klorat
diye bir şey vermiş Hatta perklorat
vermiş O yüzden yüzden bu yanlıştır
Cevap e seçeneğidir a bak çok güzel
Burada bana bazı anyon ve katyonlar
vermiş bunların arasında oluşacak
bileşikleri soruyor hangisi oluşmaz diye
soruyor bak bakır + 1 ya hepsini
yazacağım burada 9 tane bileşik
yazacağım bakır + 1 brom -1 olduğu için
+ 1 -1 sıfırladı cubr birer tane yazarak
yapabilirim Şuna bak bakırla S'ye
bakarsan s -2 ise Bakırın da + 2
toplamının + 2 olması lazım ki toplam
yük 0 olsun o zaman bu ikisi arasında
bileşik oluşursa cu2 s olur iki tane
bakır bir tane s olması lazım po 4 -3
diyor bu taraf -3 ise diğer tarafın da
toplamının + 3 olması için bakırdan 3
tane almalıyım cp4 şeklinde yazılmalı
bakalım bunlarla ilgili var mı cu2 po4
diye bir şey yok Sonuçta po4 -3 aldığı
için sanki birincisi kafadan yok gibi
duruyor ama cubr vardı Tamam onu
işaretledikten de birer tane nh4 + 1 S
-2 şimdi bir taraf -2 bir taraf + 1 o
zaman artı tarafından 2 tane olması
lazım yani
nh42s olması lazım tık Bu Da doğru oldu
Gördüğün gibi Hatta şöyle
işaretleyebilir dememem lazım ya Demek
ki Bundan 3 tane almalıyım bundan da bir
tane almalıyım Heh gelelim üçüncüye
alümin + 3 olduğuna göre brom da ne
olmuş burada -1 olduğuna göre nasıl
yapabilirim + 3'ü -3 yapmam lazım broman
3 tane lazım değil mi al BR 3 böyle
gösterebilirim ikincisi mesela al + 3 S
- 2 eşitlemek için + 6 -6 diyebilirim
bundan 2 tane Bundan 3 tane olsa + 6 -6
eşitlendi yani al2 S3 olur mu Olur
bakalım onunla ilgili örnekler var mı
yok 3üncü Bak alpo4 1 + 3 1 -3 e yükler
eşit zaten o zaman zaman ne yapacağız
birer tane yazacağız bu şekilde oldu
yani bu Doğrudur biz yanlışı bulmuştuk
zaten cevabımız a seçeneğidir şöyle de
göstereyim diyor ki Baryum + 2 ve sülfat
-2 iyonları arasında oluşacak bileşiğin
formülünü ve adını soruyor bak Baryum +
2 sülfat -2 e + 2 -2 yükler eşit değil
mi dostum E demek ki ikisinden de birer
tane alırsam olay biter B4 olacaktır
baso4 Aha Bunlar e bileşiğin ismi Baryum
ve sülfat var baryum sülfat var mı
Baryum sülfat var Cevap da C seçeneği
Evet dostum ne yapmış olduk iyonik bağlı
bileşiklerin adlandırmasını detaylı bir
şekilde işlemeye çalıştım tekrar
hatırlatıyorum o tabloyu Al karşına asz
baka baka oradan bir tane seç Buradan
bir tane artı ve eksiden seçe seçe
bileşiği de adlandır bileşiğin formülünü
de yaz Bu şekilde çok güzel pratik
olacak sana beni dinlediğin için
teşekkür ederim kanala abone olmanı
Senden rica ediyorum lütfen kanala abone
olursan daha güzel içeriklerle karşında
olacağım Bunu unutmamanı istiyorum İki
fosfor bir asit kimya Bu kadar basit bir
sonraki derste gör görüşmek üzere hoşça
kal